Zarina is in Raleigh hi Serena how are
you hi Matt Sorum damn good on yourself
better than I deserve what's up so I
need some sound advice for myself and my
husband we are newlyweds we've been
married for six months and now we are
looking at combining our finances but he
is a little bit nervous together we have
a total of 137 thousand dollars in
student loans where mine is over a
hundred and eleven thousand and his is a
lot less did he know did he know this
when you got married yes sir he did he
say the vows at the altar that said for
richer for poorer in sickness and health
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
did he mean it why are your finances not
combined because he's nervous about my
family and how I handled my finances
with them I you give your family money
without talking to your husband well
before we got married I used to live
with my parents so I paid for half of
the mortgage and I pay for other bills
still and you got married why you half
the mortgage for somebody else when you
have a hundred eleven thousand dollars
in student loan debt yes sir why because
my parents are in their 80s and they
don't work do they not have Social
Security we're not from this country sir
no sir okay did your husband know that
you were obligated to take care of your
80 year old parents when you got married
he did but he also would like some help
from my siblings and that's one part
where I'm nervous to talk to my siblings
about it I'm not it's overdue
I agree with your husband he would like
to combine our finances but because of
the situation that I'm in he doesn't
know how to go about doing that
well the way he would go about it is is
that the two of you come into agreement
on what you are willing to do to support
your parents when you lived there
it was perfectly logical that you took
care of half the mortgage because you
were a roommate
with them now that you don't live there
anymore and you have your own household
it now becomes a charitable act two
aging parents that you take care of the
mortgage which should be shared with
siblings I agree with him yesterday like
before you got married this should have
been talked about to your siblings I'm
moving out and we're all taking care of
mom and dad splitsies yes sir that's
where I have to start doing that you
know and I think you know you agree to
do that so you're you think your
siblings aren't going to want to take
care of your parents I'm sure that they
would if they could but all of them I
don't come from a financially stable
household we were never taught how to
save or do any of that so everyone is
working to get to pay and how much does
it take to support your mom and dad
about 2,000 u.s. are they in the car
they in the u.s. yeah okay my siblings
most of them are not okay 2000 US per
month
yes that's covering and what is your and
what is your household income you and
your new husband our household income
after taxes eighty thousand nine hundred
and seventy six dollars so you're making
about a hundred and two hundred and
three right yes sir
okay well that's pretty good news and
your siblings how many of them are there
I have seven in total okay
well here's what it sounds like if I'm
at your house you guys have to talk this
through okay we can't put your parents
in the street no that is not an option
okay what do your parents have any
income or any assets not in the US
what income and assets do they have
outside the US if they went back home
they have their own property and they
don't have much expenses there right and
so where is home
the way you Central America okay and
what is that property worth were they to
sell it probably about sixty thousand
u.s. and that would take care of about
thirty months I have one brother living
there so we can't sell them we can sell
it he can move and rent it's not his
property this is so listen I understand
taking care of your parents and I want
you to be doing that I don't want to put
old people on the street that is not my
heart but I agree with your husband that
there's a toxic thing going on here and
the only one that's getting written is
you nobody else is doing what they're
supposed to do in this whole story your
parents aren't selling their property
your brothers and sisters aren't
chipping in what they can ship in now if
I were your husband I would say listen I
am fine helping to support them as long
as everybody puts in something I think
necessarily equal because I understand
they're in a different country they
don't necessarily have the income but
everybody puts in something I don't care
if it's fifty dollars everybody puts in
something and the property back homes
being sold let's pretend you were broke
what would they do no I mean wow that's
true cuz you got a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt
but I'm saying you'd let us pretend you
didn't have any options here to
participate what would happen to mom and
dad they would sell the property back
home to keep from being in the street or
they moved back home and live in that
property one that they wouldn't they
okay and once we combine our finances
and get that out what would be your best
advice for us to tackle this huge loan
that we have head-on as fast as you can
living on nothing it's going to be
somewhat slowed by the money you used to
help take care of your parents
and I suggest to your husband that he
agreed is something where you do
participate in taking care of your
parents if the property is sold and the
other siblings participate at some level
but if they're all gonna leave it all on
you I'm gonna leave it all on them and
let them figure it out because I think
they're being stubborn and milking you
like you're a cow
I think everybody's got a place to play
here and nobody's playing but you so if
I'm your husband I would I would have to
be willing to take care of your mom and
dad but not when no one else is
participating including your mom and dad
but not selling the property because
your brothers living in it he needs to
go get a place to live that's what he
needs to do or they need to move back
there and live with him I would work too
maybe that's a better idea it's up to
y'all I don't care but you just
wholesale taking care of them is not
proper I do agree with your husband on
that